foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
body count where we tally up the victims
of all our favorite Marvel heroes I'm
Vera Wilde and today we'll be tallying
the victims of Captain America who made
his first debut in December of 1940 even
though the cover date on that first
issue says March 1941. the character was
created by Joe Simon Jack Kirby for
timely Comics which would later down the
line be renamed to Marvel Comics in the
1960s the cover features an iconic image
of cap punching Hitler directly into the
face and it's really important to
realize what a statement this was at the
time when this comic first hit shelves
the USA was not yet involved in the war
and there were in fact strong movements
within the country to stay out of it so
for a hero clad in the colors of the
American flag to be depicted punching a
foreign leader who we were not at war
with at the time and in fact showing him
doing that a full year ahead of the
bombing of pro Harbor which finally
prompted American involvement that was a
bold move for Simon Kirby and timely
Comics to make Captain America is also
known as Steve Rogers a good-hearted
embodiment of everything that this
country strives to be bulked up by the
so-called super soldier serum which is
lost after being used on him due to the
assassination of the man who invented it
Steve fought in World War II naturally
but towards the end of that war found
himself frozen in ice only to later be
revived decades later this is actually a
retcon of sorts you see after the war
ended the popularity of superheroes
declined across the board with all but
the biggest names like Superman or
Batman eventually seeing their books
canceled this happened to Captain
America as well whose comic ended in
1949. Atlas Comics which was what the
publisher was called after timely but
before Marvel attempted to revive the
character in the 1950s as Captain
America commie Smasher that didn't last
very long but it did mean that when the
character came back for good in 1964 at
the now re-christened of Marvel Comics
Jack Kirby and Stan Lee decided to wreck
Khan Kami Smasher cap as an imposter and
came up with the Frozen and Ice gimmick
cementing part of his role in the comics
Universe being that of a Man Out of Time
Captain America has never gone away
since though his popularity hasn't
always been consistent a poorly aged
cartoon multiple attempts at TV series
and a very boring low budget movie
probably didn't help in that regard
but you know what did
2011's Captain America the First Avenger
the last of the origin stories for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe before the big
genre defining Mega smash that was The
Avengers portrayed to near Perfection by
Chris Evans Captain America appears
prominently in seven films before the
character was retired at the conclusion
of Avengers end game oh uh I should have
actually noted this back in the Iron Man
video while I am going to be taking
Disney Plus shows into account for some
of the characters I intend to do with
this series I will not be including
anything from the what if series since I
don't see any reason why Maine
University should get credits for the
actions of his variants the Multiverse
it
it just really complicates these things
anyways Captain America is stalwart
Noble at times stubborn to a fault and
refuses to compromise his ideals however
as a war veteran who saw active combat
those ideals don't include anything like
a no-kill rule that being said Steve's
weapon of choice is one of the least
lethal items in the MCU his vibranium
Shield able to absorb impacts vibrations
and nearly indestructible The Shield is
used both offensively and defensively
frequently being thrown in a manner that
would be physics defying if it wasn't
made of a fictional material with really
vague properties that thing does not
obey the laws of physics at all when
Captain America isn't throwing his
mighty Shield he's skilled in
hand-to-hand combat boosted by his
enhanced strength and endurance from the
super soldier serum while Steve doesn't
really have any qualms about picking up
a gun and appears quite handy with the
money does it's pretty rare for him to
be equipped with one as standard issue
after he's off of the wartime front so
with that in mind how many people does
cap kill in his time wielding The Shield
uh but before we get to that a quick
reminder in case you skipped the Iron
Man video I'm only going to be counting
deaths of people who can be labeled as
sentient and or Sapient and while that
does not preclude non-humans for being
counted it does mean that I don't count
anything that behaves as a horde or a
hive mind these kind of groups would
include the Ultron Bots those
multi-limbed beasties that bulk out
thanos's Army and of course the chittari
from the first Avengers movie I made my
case for considering them a hive mind
back in the Iron Man video so if you're
tempted to fight me on this point you
can check out that and see my full
explanation as to why I ultimately made
the call that I did beyond that I am
operating largely on my own instincts as
to whether something appears to be
lethal or not and I largely got to base
that off of the nature of the damage the
sound effects used I am rapidly
developing an ear for bone crunching
sound effects
and also the general tropes of the genre
at no point am I doing a realistic
assessment of physical damage I'm not a
doctor these injuries are never
presented realistically in these kinds
of films anyway and that's just not how
we're approaching this all on the same
page good
let's count the bodies in his first
outing Steve was serving militarily in
war so you'd expect him to rack up a
decent number once he's all Juiced up
and out in the field well initially when
he is out trying to free prisoners from
Hydra he appears to be going non-lethal
beating up and by all indication
knocking out two soldiers in a truck and
one more upon arrival at the base
another knockout once inside and then
one more before freeing the prisoners
and it's starting to look like cap might
be going for the no kill run on this
Mission later he does kick a guy over a
railing but it's kind of hard to tell
how far that guy fell and whether or not
he landed on anything that would have
killed him and the general layout of the
area is such that I'm not inclined to
count it now granted that guy almost
definitely dies later when the Munitions
are detonated but that's Red Skull who
sets the charges so Steve doesn't get
credit for that later on we see the good
Captain breaking down a door guns
blazing but we never see a reverse angle
so who knows if he hit anything or what
he was even shooting at we get a montage
of Shield hits and explosions but
nothing that I could comfortably confirm
as a Kill
however at the tail end of the Montage
we do have the detonation of this I
Mega tank initially he throws a guy off
I'm not counting that as fatal it's not
high enough however he then drops in
explosives and the whole thing goes boom
in the Iron Man body count I went over
the fact that the standard crew in a
tank is for but that was for modern day
tanks World War II tanks could be up to
six and that's for just a standard crew
for this Beast I'm gonna say it's more
than that so here's how I'm figuring
this the standard crew of six plus one
more for each placement of guns because
I'm assuming every gun is intended to be
operated simultaneously while in motion
so there is the big gun up top a set of
Hydra lasers underneath that and a pair
of guns on either side since the lasers
have their own power source and the side
guns just look like they're High Caliber
but otherwise standard Weaponry I'm
gonna be assuming that it's only the big
cannon that requires a dedicated hated
loader in addition to the Gunner so the
three others should only need one gun or
a piece with no loaders required so with
our standard crew of six which would
include the loader for the big gun plus
one for each of the three gun turrets
minus the one guy who gets thrown out by
Steve when he opened up the tank gives
us a count of eight for this explosion
the tank is big enough that it could
have had more people than that in it but
this is the number I'm comfortable with
after that there's the raid on the train
where Cap eventually loses Bucky for the
time being Steve takes down a big boy
with a blaster and it looks more like a
knockout to me now cap does give an
assist to Bucky with his kills but I'm
not counting those towards his score oh
uh and I can't confirm the big guy was
only knocked out because he shows up
again and causes the train to tear open
cap hits him with the shield but I'm
counting that as another knockout if for
no other reason then Cap's too busy
trying to say Bucky to make sure the guy
stays down which means no kills on this
a little action scene but now it's time
for some motorcycle action let's see if
Steve is willing to get his hands dirty
here a couple of hydra agents get
clothes lined off their bikes which
doesn't look pleasant but I'm not gonna
count that as fatal but then cap busts
out a rear firing flamethrower a guy
goes down completely engulfed in flames
uh yeah that one's gonna get counted
another flips off the bike and you know
what initially I wasn't going to count
this one because we don't see how he
lands but here's the thing
he gets the classic Wilhelm scream
and that scream is used almost
exclusively on characters who are never
getting back up again
so what the heck I'll give it to him I
will also count these two that cap just
blows up all casual like he then blows
up a tank with rockets now it's a normal
tank not a mega tank and it's big enough
that I'm going to assume the upper end
of crew sizes for the time which as I
mentioned would be six when Captain
America infiltrates the base there's an
explosion and one Hydra agent goes down
there's another guy who flails and drops
down but I can't for the life of me tell
what hit him there's a laser blast like
in the shot but it's nowhere near the
guy I honestly I think he's just a drama
queen we get some Shield smacks another
explosion but it doesn't feel close
enough to anybody for me to feel
comfortable counting it as a kill for
any of them and that scene gets wrapped
up as Steve gets surrounded it's not too
long after that that backup arrives cap
puts a Hydra agent between himself and
the Red Skull the guy gets blasted and
with every indication that cap
intentionally used him as a human shield
so yeah I'll count that one even though
it was Red Skull who hold the trigger
from here most kills are going to go to
the soldiers who come in blazing there's
a few more knock downs and punches but
the real action for what's left in this
movie comes on the Red Skulls getaway
plane inside of it Steve takes on
several goons the first few look like
Knockouts but then he takes one out with
a knife causes a situation that makes
one of them drop from the plane and flat
out throws another one off so that's
three right there when Steve finds
himself fighting a Hydra agent on a mini
plane the agent does ultimately fall
into the propellers but that's honestly
more due to the Flying of the pilot
trying to shake Steve off so I'm not
going to give cap that one Steve does
eject the pilot of that plane but given
that the plane even had an eject feature
I feel like it's safe to assume that
there are means for the pilot to land
safely parachute something
but you know then again
by this time they'd be over the ocean
he's just going to end up way too far
from Land he's going to drown so you
know what heck I'll give that one to him
after that it's just cap versus The Red
Skull and we know from later movies that
whatever happened to good old Johann
Schmidt it didn't properly kill him so
that wraps up Captain America's debut
film after that it's the big team up
with the Avengers
but as I alluded to and went over in the
Iron Man body count video the chatari
act as a hive mind as evidenced by all
of them dropping when the mothership
blows up and I do not count parts of a
hive mind as individual kills so that
means the only kill cap gets in this
entire big Team Up movie is throwing
this guy off the Helicarrier this guy
who was under mind control from Loki and
was probably a decent sort otherwise
might have even had a family with a like
a new puppy and everything
nice one Steve
real nice on the captain's next solo
outing the Winter Soldier the first
action scene has Steve Natasha AKA Black
Widow and a few others taking on Pirates
on an anchored boat cap goes for
Chokehold and shield smashes for most of
the goons on deck which I'm still gonna
count as non-lethal Knockouts now there
is this guy who goes overboard and I
went back and forth on him if the ship
had been in motion I'd have assumed he
got left behind and drowned but with it
being anchored it's possible he could
still get back on board
except there's some crunchy sound
effects in play here
so I feel like his legs might have been
broken on impact with the railing I
think I'm gonna call this one drowned
another guy goes over the railing but
not nearly as violently so he's probably
okay and then the rest of the on Deck
hits are just Knockouts later on there's
this Shield throw that batroc ducks and
it hits this other guy in the head
before embedding in the wall and given
how hard that was thrown and the fact
that it was definitely a headshot
I'm saying this guy's dead yeah yeah I
know there should be Blood on the shield
and there isn't but I don't care look at
this hit normally when thrown The Shield
bounces off guys this went right through
him he's gone there's the one-on-one
fight with batroc but no deaths there so
let's move on to our next action beat
well um the next one that involves Steve
anyway badass as Nick Fury's car chase
is he's not in my current plans for this
series sorry Nick so uh that then brings
us to the elevator fight also pretty
dang badass it's also all Knockouts and
also no kills during cap subsequent
Escape because the plane he takes down
lands surprisingly softly all things
considered during the shootout on the
street with Hydra Steve deliberately
deflects bullet fire to Ricochet and
take out a Hydra agent but otherwise
he's playing defense on this one from
there we can jump to the finale with the
Helicarrier launch and the Hydra vs
Shield battle
it's mostly knockout hits through this
though cap does set off this grenade
that initially I was gonna say wasn't
close enough to these guys to take them
out but on closer inspection that's
really right in their faces so that's
three right there but after that it's
Knockouts with some impressive leg work
but nothing fatal
so we move on time for the next team up
anyone who already watched the Iron Man
body count already knows what a massive
pain in the ass the opening action scene
of Age of Ultron was it's especially
difficult with a character like cap
whose weapon may be the single most
capable of being used non-lethally out
of the entire team and because this
action scene is framed around a forward
assault on the hydro base and everything
is propelling forward the need for both
the team and the action to keep moving
means I can't get a reference for how
hard a lot of these guys went down
whether or not it looked like they would
ever get back up so uh yeah gonna be a
lot of judgment calls on this one and
due to all that I expect this is a
section I'm more liable to get some
disagreement on but uh here we go cap
rides into the scene on a motorcycle and
starts by grabbing this guy by the leg
and then proceeding to drag him along
the ground before hurling him at his
buddies and I agonized on this one a
little bit because that is a rough bit
of treatment
but we know the Hydra agent didn't take
a lethal or even knockout damage from
being dragged along because he yells
once he's airborne and as a general rule
in action scenes one villain thrown into
others is usually treated as a knockdown
so I won't be counting the guy thrown or
the two guys he landed on next up Steve
takes out a few in Rapid succession with
the shield and knocks this guy over a
ledge now it's feasible that that fall
might be fatal however given that Steve
didn't have a big drop when he jumps his
motorcycle down shortly after I'm
assuming that the Hydra agent fell from
a comparable height and so I'm gonna say
that's survivable there's a shield
backhand that I almost missed but again
nothing about it looks any harder than
what I've been considering knockout
blows so far in this video after that
we've got the Star-Spangled Avenger
throwing his motorcycle at a Jeep and
causing it to flip over now I spotted
four guys riding in this thing but one
of the most have realized what was about
to happen because he's actually already
trying to LEAP out of the Jeep when the
motorcycle impacts without being able to
see how he lands I'm not prepared to
confirm that guy as a kill that leaves
the three still in the Jeep now I did
notice that it doesn't land in a way
that actually puts them on their heads
because it kind of spins slightly lands
on its side
now that leaves me a little bit of
wiggle room but given the impact of the
motorcycle I'm definitely going to call
the two in the front as dead even though
the actual direct impact was not on
either one of their sides but actually
dead in between them but the speed at
which this thing hits I'm still gonna
err on the side of saying that the third
guy didn't make it either so that's
three more for Steve a little later we
see him go hand to hand with some goons
and while I won't count any of these as
kills there's a moment I want to
highlight anyway just to give something
close to hard evidence that most of the
time a shield throw is
non-fatal you can see here cap bounces
The Shield off of the heads of several
of these guys and then has to deck this
one a second time because he's still
standing that to me is a good solid case
that unless there is something
significantly different about a throw as
was noted with the Winter Soldier
embedded in the wall throw barring
something like that I'm comfortable
calling Shield hits as Knockouts by
default then we have this combo move
with Thor and cap and this one could
have gone a few ways now first off I
suspect some would argue for this Force
wave as being non-lethal since it mostly
appears to just be knocking guys aside
but the thing is that same wave rips the
top of a tank off at a point when it
should be losing energy and that kind of
force I'm calling that lethal yes it
would have been more consistent for the
hydro thugs to be shredded by that but
yeah you know PG-13 same reason there
was no blood on the shield when cap took
the guy out on the boat but now as then
because the demonstrated force is so
destructive I'm calling it lethal
anyways but the problem then becomes
who do I give credit for this because
the blow originates from Thor and that
blow gets enhanced and directed by The
Shield but the shield is being used
mostly just to direct it and to channel
some of the power from the hammer I did
consider splitting the count giving half
to each of them but
ultimately I think what makes this legal
is rooted more in Thor's contribution
than caps so uh you're actually gonna
have to wait for the Thor video to find
out how many were taken out there Steve
then confronts strucker non-lethally and
that wraps up this opening stretch of
action as for the back end of the film
I've established before the Ultron Bots
I consider to be non-sentient and a
horde so they are not going to be
counted however there is one other
action scene that does involve people
and that's the one on the tanker where
some of claws minions get involved cap
spends most of that fight dealing with
an Ultron bot and the shield hits and
throws we do see don't look hard enough
to count as fatal and then at that point
he gets whammyed by Wanda so he's out
for the remainder of that fight and the
rest of the movie from there on out is
Ultron and Ultron bots so we'll move on
from here now for civil war while the
airport fight is all heroes nobody dies
in the opening confrontation with some
of the remnants of Hydra and Leb by
crossbones there's some action here
Steve comes in hard with this first hit
I wouldn't normally count a body slam as
fatal but cap came in from the air and
slammed full force into the sky shield
first he might as well have slammed a
car into him
I really want to call him dead but we
then get confirmation that these guys
are in body armor body armor AR-15s
which in real life would not have saved
him from an impact like that but
we're also going by movie logic so
okay yeah fine he lives betcha he never
walks a straight line again but it's
fine there are a few kills in that
opening sequence but they go to Sam who
I don't plan to do unless this series
does well enough for me to cover phase
two now as for crossbones while he does
go down following a confrontation with
cap that is from self detonation and
that'll do it for civil war so because
of my not counting mindless hordes the
good old Star Spangled superhero
actually doesn't land a single kill in
either Infinity war or end game tank cap
why you gotta be so lazy
obviously I'm joking the man works his
ass off but all of the named characters
or ones with confirmed mental autonomy
get taken out by other combatants or by
Tony's final sacrificial snap
so that actually means cap goes through
his final three films only punching the
tickets of monsters and horde beasts and
so we're done and we need to now take a
look at the final numbers in his time as
Captain America Steve Rogers racked up a
total of 34 kills and like Iron Man
before him the vast majority of those
were in his first appearance with
significant appearances in seven films
that give Steve an average body count of
4.86 kills per movie This Is Well behind
Iron Man Who had a total of 82 kills and
an average of 9.11 kills per movie
looking at a breakdown the vast majority
of bodies left behind by Captain America
were done in by some form of explosion
with the second most common cause
involving some sort of fall from a
significant height the rest are a
smattering of blunt force trauma bullet
Ricochet putting someone between himself
and harm and that one time that cap used
the shield itself to kill somebody
unlike Tony though Steve didn't take out
any sentient non-humans so all of his
skills were just normal squishy people
none of them even had any superhero
enhancements
so the super soldier serum-powered hero
only ever killed guys who were nowhere
near his level of skill and strength
Jesus when I say I like that it almost
makes cap seem like a bully
I'm kidding again of course being a
bully just isn't about physical strength
it's a mentality of picking on the weak
and the vulnerable for selfish reasons
and Captain America proved again and
again that is absolutely not who he is
and he wouldn't stand for that behavior
when he saw it the last time I was in
Germany
saw a man standing above everybody else
we ended up disagreeing
so
that'll wrap up this entry in the MCU
body count come back in two months where
I will go from the Avenger with the
least Lethal Weapon of Choice to the one
who might well have the most lethal
go-to weapon as we take a look at the
bodies left behind by Clint Barton AKA
Hawkeye with five movies and a series to
go through can Hawkeye challenge the
likes of Steve or Tony who both had more
appearances than he did find out in
November and that will wrap up this one
what did you think of this was it higher
than you thought was it lower were you
surprised that I did or didn't count
certain things whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it if you think I
made a mistake that's a good place to
put that too but if you want to support
this series or anything else I do
patreon's the best way to do it and I
absolutely appreciate every single bit
of support I get through that but don't
worry too much about it like share
subscribe help me in the algorithm as
well so I definitely appreciate those
but what I really want you to remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and in the case of this series
counting up the bodies and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
Robin Moore Zubin lotfulla to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime
Oliver B and Linda Walters imodelki the
oatha Boyd Becky Sparks for nobody likes
the poodle Zach eidolin Tracy scrabot
angry Casper Adam RDL Taylor Shane Ross
Shaylee gourlay Brendan Larose and TT
[Music]
if you want your name set while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards on my
patreon
[Music]